this is Startalk let me ask just to get
a little philosophical on you as a
scientist and I grew up basically in the
geekus sphere and I even know I may be
the last generation of those officially
trained on how to use a slide rule by
the way I was gonna bring one tonight
and just kind of show off you know but I
still have my sling so got your slide
rule say so
so if we I'm curious when we think of
who is smart in the class it's who knows
the most who can solve a problem the
most it's not the person who's most
emotional generally we don't use the
word smart for that person yet you are
grouping that feature of what it is to
be human as something that computers
have yet a place where computers have
yet to tread and when they do they'll
then be truly smarter than us but if
your emotions for example interfere with
your ability to make a the correct
decision given the outcome you seek how
can we call I possibly call that
intelligence well I mean you go around
with a comedian for some of your
presentations recognizing that humor is
in fact a high form of intelligence it
takes a lot of intelligence to think of
what he's referring to is that the star
talk radio show my co-host is always a
professional stand-up comedian
bringing a level of levity to the
conversation and inside
I mean humor is a high form of
intelligence and creating poetic
language it's a form of intelligence
expressing a loving sentiments music
either recreating it or creating in the
first place these are these are really
the highest forms of intelligence
computers are beginning to encroach on
that like so what you say enough to put
words in your mouth but that's exactly
what I'm gonna do all right what you're
saying is right now the computer can
wipe our floor in a game of chess that
we invented the computer can beat us
jeopardy a game that we invented and
it's based basically on pop culture and
now I'm go which is a couple I go the
the territory game right so so the
computer can beat us at all of these
things it still can't beat us in our
capacity to write a brilliant novel or
to compose a beautiful poem or to paint
a transcendent
yeah pretty it's a step in that all
right gotcha so I'm asking you is are
you saying the day will come where the
computer will write the Nobel
prize-winning novel and the poem that
generations will study thereafter and
supplant even that aspect of what it is
to be human right but I put it
differently in that we're going to
combine without intelligence we're going
to become a merger of biological and
non-biological intelligence we are
already so still be humans who do that
we create hands we create these tools to
you know extend our reach this allows us
to remember all of your menage we can
build great structures like this
building here which you couldn't do with
our bare muscles so we extend our reach
and we're going to do that
intellectually and we're doing that
already
but it's gonna become more profound so
you're you're ready to erase the
difference between a machine that has
this power and a human that has been
enhanced by that which ever gave the
machine power in the first place but I
mean you know what is a human but it's a
collection of physical stuff which
follows the laws of physics it's not you
know a mystical property we can study a
neuron and it is a machine so we are
perhaps the most complex machine that we
know about in the universe but so then
the individuality will go away because
we will all have exactly the same on the
taxes on the contrary will become more
different we're actually more the same
now we all have the same architecture
300 million neocortical modules yeah but
we both eat the same set of nanobots and
it goes through our frontal lobe so on
we are we still the same now with
nanobots running around our head now we
can become more different because right
now we have the same architecture brain
now we may fill it with different
thoughts and
marvin minsky you died recently was my
mentor and he wrote a book called the
society of mind
basically describing our neocortex as a
society of different factions that fight
each other and so some of those
societies are more effective because
they're harmonious and working together
and some of our societies of mind are at
war with each other and therefore we're
ineffective but we have basically the
same architecture so what you're saying
is with this new architecture there are
more places to go emotionally and
intellectually exact so that if I have
leanings whatever is causing that
towards poetry rather than physics I can
then be a great poet enhanced by all of
the nanobots that allow it you can
profoundly study and master poetry or
music or in a in a deeper way than we
can today because we'll have more brain
power to apply